seit wochen wüten putins truppen
zerstören ganze städte ermorden
zivilisten die russische führung
versucht aber weiter auf perfide weise
das morden zu rechtfertigen davon
entnazifizierung der ukraine ist da die
rede von einer spezialoperation und wenn
sie jetzt glauben die russische
propaganda könnte nicht per feder und
absurder werden dann hören sie mal was
außenminister lavrov gesagt hat
ich höre diese lenski sagen dass wir in
den verhandlungen nicht einmal über
entmilitarisierung und entnazifizierung
sprechen möchten ich denke dass die
ukraine diese verhandlungen sabotieren
genau wie zuvor die minsker
vereinbarungen außerdem gibt es in der
ukraine nazis ukrainische bataillone von
asa von qaida und andere einheiten
tragen das hakenkreuz und ss symbole auf
der kleidung und auf ihrer haut sie
lesen und propagieren hitlers mein kampf
selenz gesagt wie können wir nazis sein
wenn ich doch jude bin vielleicht irre
ich mich aber hitler hatte auch
jüdisches blut es bedeutet absolut
nichts die weißen juden sagen dass die
leidenschaftlichsten antisemiten
normalerweise
judentum hast nur zu viel kürzer
also da bleibt einem fast der mund offen
stehen wenn man das hört darüber müssen
wir natürlich sprechen und zwar mit bild
-chef reporterin antonia armin schön
dass du bei uns bist was waren deine
gedanken als du das gehört das also man
muss schon sagen warface außenminister
von russland ist aber auch nur zwei in
russland der ist fast der wichtigste
mensch nach routine und wenn man in so
hoher denkt man er hat gestern abend
vielleicht die falsche tablette
geschluckt so ihre hat es sich ja auch
an aber das ist tatsächlich eine sehr
geplante und sehr gefährliche taktik
dass er da furth und auch nicht zum
ersten mal man schmeißt seit wochen lang
alles in den topf nazis hitler die
ukraine den salewski und jetzt halt auch
die juden das dient natürlich dazu dass
die dieses gefühl von dritten weltkrieg
ein totaler krieg das dient genau zu
diesem gefühl und ihnen so einem ich
darf man wahrscheinlich auch alles tun
weil wenn wir jetzt wenn alle nazis sind
wenn die juden nazis sind wenn der
solvenz kinase ist dann ist butscher
okay dann ist ein atomangriff vielleicht
auch okay und jetzt ist der krieg gerade
noch in europa aber wenn man diese
sachen hort kann man sich sehr schnell
vorstellen dass es sich auch sehr
schnell es gehen kann was machen diese
äußerungen mit der jüdischen gemeinde in
russland also ich habe heute morgen mit
meiner kontakte in russland auch
gesprochen die jüdische gemeinde ist
natürlich import von diesen sachen die
dürfen aber auch nix sagen weil jeder
der was gegen der tierisches russische
regierung sagt wird auch sofort markiert
und am ende fragt man muss schon sagen
dieser satz hat er jetzt gestern live
hat den gestern im italienischen
fernsehen gesagt aber diese sätze sind
nicht für uns sich sind nicht für die
westliche welt diese aus äußerungen sind
fuhr russland gedacht es ist eine
innerliche propaganda die auch fake news
verbreitet wenn ihr jetzt im internet
schaut weniger als 24 stunden nach
dieser äußerung seht ihr schon artikeln
die fragen war hitler eigentlich ein
guter oder ein anderer artikel der meint
ja hitler war 25% jute und das
relativiert holocaust aber das
relativiert auch den antisemitismus und
gerade jude oder juden in russland zu
sein finde ich gefährlich also eine ganz
perfide art und weise das ganze
irgendwie zu relativieren und irgendwie
scheint es dann eben wie man sieht auch
ein bisschen zu funktionieren leider ich
bin mir sicher das ganze wird auch in
israel scharf diskutiert wie wird das
aufgenommen wie sind die reaktionen also
in israel ist es ein riesenskandal
außenminister jaap der auch selbst sohn
eines holocaust- überlebende ist hat
heute morgen schon sehr stark kritisiert
und meinte das ist unverzeihlich wäre
dass es natürlich ein historischer
fehler ist und das am endeffekt juden
nicht sich selbst im holocaust ermordet
haben was natürlich eigentlich ganz
normal und
jeder soll es wissen aber mit solchen
sprüchen kommt man nicht weiter
unfassbar antonia jamin danke dass du
bei uns war es danke für deine ganz
aktuelle einschätzung der tanke